without eight in there you can see thee
and now we've gotten more gijang and
devin booker having words which the AC
step again along with Kelly who pray you
break coming to the defense of his
teammates and
[Applause]
Acey stepping in there as well
the fishes will certainly come take a
look at it as we will also
[Music]
here's what
set it all up
they're big guys I'm telling it's
hoarsely they just stick that elbow up
that's what they do and he caught Devin
and that was a fire without a doubt
really gonna look at it to see if it's
flagrant Devin didn't like it I don't
know if Jang said anything to him but
that's when the confrontation started to
happen
[Music]
[Music]
yes they're gonna look at gorgeous elbow
seemed like they were gonna look at it
initially now they aren't gonna come
over a ticket well maybe after the play
when both player got together
in the May fight no glove is in vain no
glove
now there are there are gloves igloo
justice back-alley fighting that said
extreme fighting underground men's
clothes fight
rated number one in
here it is
what players having a little words and
yeah well that was probably gonna hit my
hand up her there in the face if I could
push to the face the words he like bill
back like oh he hit me hard
I got double technicals one on him when
they both out of here oh wow double text
and they're both long
that is certainly a far greater loss for
the Timberwolves than it is the Sun
[Applause]
Suns losing TJ worid
at the end of the first half
and Courtney Jang is now talking to
Devin Booker and telling hookers come
meeting in the tunnel as Booker
you know that's like the normal response
right guys knowing that you're not going
to be allowed to meet in the tongue
right not enough security personnel to
long before that's like that's like
that's like me telling Mike Tyson's like
did you meet me around the corner of of
smack you me knowing that's a lot of
people saying you think you want to do
that please I think you need to get